baldness
is hair loss or absence of hair
now doctors call it alopecia
usually the most noticeable on the scalp
but can happen anywhere in the body it
can be your armpits your chest hair
abdominal hair your groin region or even
your beards
it is more common in men than in women
because men have more hair so it's more
visible
so baldness types now female pattern of
baldness is one kind of baldness where
females start to lose hair but the
pattern is that
the thinning occurs all over the head
and there's no particular patchy
thinning
the hairline is usually maintained that
means the anterior limitation of the
hairline
and the total loss of hair is usually
rare which is more common in males
whereas there's a pattern known as a
Ludwig pattern where there's a gradual
recession of The Parting line of the
hair
then there's another pattern known as a
male pattern of baldness where there is
inherited condition the hairline recedes
that means the hairline over your
forehead goes back and finally there's a
total loss of hair is common
then there's another medical condition
known as alopecia areata where there is
patchy loss of all hair
may involve other parts
apart from scalp like your beard
readings your eyebrows your armpits your
chest groin Etc now genetic and
autoimmune associations may be present
but not proved yet
now there's another condition known as
trichotillomania which is a
psychological condition in which a
person pulls his or her own hair out
now this is usually seen in Youngs and
young adults and can be treated by
psychological methods
now what causes baldness now the causes
can be genetic or they can be
environmental now genetic factors
includes a sex influence trait that
means if a male has one recessive allele
he will show that trait but it will take
two recessive for the female to show the
same trait
then environmental factors include
stressful hairstyles like tight
ponytails that pull your hair a lot then
there can be drugs or supplements
radiation therapy stress nutritional
deficiency all can lead to hair loss now
how we diagnose baldness now baldness
diagnosis depends on
the clinical history and examination
presence of chronic illness or drug or
medication use or even a supplement use
now diagnosis is mostly made by
physicians particularly dermatologists
now how they treat baldness so the
treatment can be a medical by applying
medicine over the bald area or if that
method fails then you can go for a hair
transplant surgery where healthy hairs
are transplanted over your bald area
this summarizes the idea of baldness now
to get notes and flashcards from our
site you can follow us on our Facebook
and Instagram page at animated biology
with arpan the link will be in the
description also to provide high quality
educational content for free we need
your support and to support us you can
use a super thanks icon to support our
channel that is in the bottom right
corner of any video and you can pay
using paytm PayPal or for Indians it can
be UPI as well
now if you wish to connect with arpan
the connection links will be given in
the description box below this video was
made in collaboration with the nerd
medic who creates medicine related
content on YouTube his connection links
are given over here until then bye bye
see you in the next one